how long can a human survive without
water
and how long can a human survive
drinking only their own urine I'm asking
for a friend
three days without water is typical your
guidelines to work around if you're
conserving a lot and not doing much you
can extend it a little bit what about
drinking your own pee which we hear done
yeah people do that that is not
advisable because that will make you a
little more dehydrated and help
accumulate a lot of the toxins that is
the waste product in your urine in your
body so not advisable if you can distill
it just like how we do it on space
stations right that would be an
excellent choice and with some simple
tools a few buckets
um things that you can carve you can
make improvised distillation setup in
the woods